Thank you for joining us today.
>> Thanks It's a pleasure to be here.
>> Let's get started.
So given a 2D matrix,
m, of just 0s and 1s,
count the number of
islands in the matrix.
In this case an island is just
a group of 1s or a 1 by itself.
>> Okay, so we're given a 2D matrix.
Which would look something like this.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So what we're to do is we're
to find the number of islands.
Where an island is
a group of 1s connected.
But if 1s are connected diagonally,
does that constitute an island?
>> No, the 1s need to be
connected either horizontally or
vertically to count as an island.
>> Okay, so
what we're really supposed to do is find
the number of islands in this matrix.
Where an island is 1s connected
horizontally and vertically.
>> That's exactly right.
>> Cool.
>> All right, how do you think
our interview we did for
the first portion of the interview?
>> Well I think he didn't do too bad.
You clarified the question to make sure
that he's solving the right problem.
>> Right.
This is a very popular
interview question, so
there are different variations.
It's important to make sure you're
solving the right variation.
Some interviewers may consider 1s
connected diagonally to be an island.
In general,
clarifying a problem is crucial to
being a good software developer.
You need to prove to your interviewer
that you won't dive head first into
a problem and
potentially waste time writing code
that doesn't solve the initial issue.